Transcriber:
When we think of solutions
to global warming,
we generally think in terms
of technology or policy,
but other approaches are necessary
which have to do with how
our societies are structured.
The most important of them
is educating and empowering
women and girls.
Now, don't take my word for it.
Its potential impact
has been calculated by scientists.
Like, for instance,
those working on Project Drawdown,
who focus on greenhouse gas emissions.
They calculated that educating
and empowering women and girls
is one of the single most important things
that we can do to confront
carbon pollution.
It may result in a total reduction
of CO2-equivalent gases
of over 80 billion tons,
which is not far from double
the total annual global emissions.
As a marine scientist
and nature adventurer,
I've witnessed firsthand
how climate change
impacts the world we live in.
These climate catastrophes
have almost taken my life.
Like when I was nearly buried alive
during an avalanche
or swept away by a cyclone.
Thankfully, I survived,
but will our grandchildren
call this planet home in 2050 or 2100
if our trajectory continues?
Coming from a male-dominated society,
I've been asked all sorts
of intrusive questions
as to why I do what I do.
"Can you even travel alone?"
"Are you capable of climbing mountains
with your heavier figure?
I mean, are you fit enough?"
"Do you think, as a woman,
you're equipped to do this?"
And the answer has always been, yes.
I want to show my fellow Arab women
that anything is possible,
that being a woman should not be
the end to your dreams,
that you are so much more
than what you are conditioned to be,
and that you are indeed the solution
to the crisis facing our planet.
In 2020, women made up about 40 percent
of the global workforce.
Women's shares in the Middle East
are just under 25 percent.
And these figures are way lower
in the Gulf countries.
And considering that women
make up nearly half of the Gulf,
imagine how women's equal
involvement in the economy
could enhance the overall
growth of the region.
Many labor laws state
that there's no discrimination
between men and women.
Yet women's upward mobility
is quite restricted
and many senior positions
are still being held by men.
The cultural perception
that women are more emotional
or better suited
to household responsibilities
remains a serious obstacle
for ambitious women
who end up underemployed.
So what does that have to do
with the climate?
Well, access to education,
employment and family planning
is the condition for more vibrant lives
for women and girls,
for their families
and their entire communities.
They get to earn more money,
achieve career goals
and face fewer health issues.
And not only that,
they become more resilient
and better equipped to manage
both food and nature
and to cope with the impacts
of climate change.
Women are also the ones most at risk
when it comes to impacts
of climate catastrophes like cyclones,
which have grown more frequent
in my own home country of Oman.
And why?
Well because they're left with a charge
of the children or elderly,
they don't know how to swim,
or simply because they never had
basic resilience skills taught to them,
like building a shelter, making a fire
or even administering basic first aid.
In fact, UN figures indicate
that 80 percent of people
displaced by climate change
are women.
And with more of these
occurrences happening,
my gender will face more of the brunt
further preventing them
from achieving their potential
and protecting themselves.
This is why I founded WomeX,
a platform where we teach women
from my community negotiation skills
to nurture a new wave
of girl bosses in the region.
WomeX is on a mission
to laying the groundwork
to combating climate change
by bridging localized context
and leadership training.
By educating more women on these skills,
we hope to equip them with the tools
that allow them to control
their careers and their lives,
and to contribute significantly
to the collective efforts
necessary to confront carbon pollution.
So far, we've supported a thousand
and are working hard to achieve
our ambitious goal of a million.
Now, even though it has been
on the global sustainability
radar for years,
gender parity as a climate solution
has not received
the attention it deserves.
Now is the time to make it a priority.
Now is the time to educate
and empower all women and all girls.
Thank you.